Londyn the most popular international
city destination in the world corner if
I'm asked welcome to the call ring come
on in one you may have ticked off the
tourist hotspots here
there's a secret side to this mega city
it's amazing that there are so many
beautiful and wild and unschooled parts
of London there's amazing graffiti and
maybe more of a local kind of life aside
that's little known to visitors take a
tour with three Londoners and access the
kind of experiences that are normally
only enjoyed by insiders I might say to
you Greek Week what parts of 3 don't you
say evens levels you Devils people in
the nerve in London this is where they
come
London's installed once known more for
its slums and the scene of the notorious
nineteenth-century murders of Jack the
Ripper now the creatives epicenter of
the city it's impossible to be bored in
East London it's really diverse it's
really creative and it's really fun
Megan clay Jones his lip all over London
but like many younger residents she's
chosen to make their home in Tower
Hamlets 15 years ago visitors never came
to these parts of London there's a real
buzz and energy running through this
community is a whole of a world that
most visitors have yet to discover
in East London everybody's head of like
Shoreditch and the trendy bars and the
clubs and things and not so many people
know that you've got these lovely canal
networks it's relaxing and quite an
inspiring place to be hi Ramona can you
is a cheap and easy way of exploring the
hidden waterways of this vibrant part of
London look there's the markzware there
so when their canal boats were pulled by
horses the road weave London went
rocketing year-on-year canal boats have
become a popular place to live there are
3000 floating homes like these on the
waterways of London
many of which run pop-up businesses lots
of the houseboats have started little
businesses so you get floating cocktail
bars you get floating book shops I even
went to a floating record store the
other day and the people who live in the
houseboats are also friendly so when
you're going past them they'll wave and
say good morning and even ask you in for
like a cup of tea at the moment we're
going past them artists studios there
are lovely cafes and bars that are off
the main thoroughfares of of London
there's amazing graffiti and maybe more
of a local kind of life yeah I think the
canals are a subculture all of their own
last year 30 million people visited
London it doesn't matter where you drive
in London every inch of this city is
filled with heritage and history and
culture
James has lived in London his whole life
kaby he seems to show off the tourist
attractions
but he usually keeps his favorite spots
to himself
London cannot boast beaches or guarantee
sunshine even in the midst of summer but
on Hampstead Heath nestled in 790 a KERS
of meadows and public park there's wild
swimming having a swim in Hampstead is
just the easiest way to get back to
nature and get away from all the stress
of the city
Hampstead ponds are just six miles from
Trafalgar Square but you'll be hard
pushed to find a more tranquil city
landscape
mixed-gender pond ponds exclusively for
men and women and even nude as there is
for just a couple of pounds it's a cheap
way to get away from it all it's amazing
there there's so many beautiful and wild
and unsupportive London most people that
visit the city will obviously kind of
gravitate towards the main tourist
attractions which tend to be really
really busy so this is a complete
antidote to that and there's a lot of
local people that we use this pond to
swim in or a regular basis but you very
rarely get to risk coming here there are
plenty of outdoor swimming leidos in
London and a handful of ponds like these
for those wanting to get back to nature
without leaving the city Belgravia in
central London is a very different kind
of habitat ground zero for the city's
social elite and home to some of
London's finest hotels
welcome to the chrome ring come on in
Dave
Morgan Hewitt is the managing director
of The Goring Hotel
brooms here cost up to eight thousand
four hundred pounds and
but afternoon tea is a far more
affordable way for visitors to
experience a slice of high-end London
luxury afternoon tea it's a completely
unnecessary meal therefore it's an
indulgence and it's quite interesting
because over the last four or five years
the afternoon tea has become
unbelievably popular here in London
thank you very much
since opening its doors in 1910 The
Goring has welcomed regulars for
afternoon tea including Margaret
Thatcher the Queen Mother and Winston
Churchill I think there's no more
indulgence British English indulgence
than afternoon tea
another refreshment londoners love is
beer and there's more shortage of
drinking holes more than 7-thousand at
last count the pop culture is in the DNA
of this city
the cabbie James prefers the less
traditional micro breweries which in
recent years have taken on a new lease
of life
opt right all right nice to see you
again if you don't know your ass from
your elbow then ordering in the British
pub can sometimes be confusing for there
if I'm asked then micro breweries are
the place to come to get to know your
beers so when you walk into a British
pub now don't be put off by the large
variety of beers on offer it's perfectly
right to ask the barman for his
recommendation have a sip take your time
before you decide the great thing about
beer is it's got a whole range of
flavors from the multi ones to the dark
ones the light hoppy ones not only can
you taste a huge variety of a lagers
Porter's and other beers you can take a
guided tour behind the scenes it's a
one-stop shop for aspiring connoisseurs
ok you know about your beer a little bit
you know that's a breeze go say oh well
I've been doing a lot of years you can
tell thick Sakhalin what's this this is
the start the process yeah we start with
malted barley in the hopper yeah we fill
that the night before we start brewery
and then we mix it with very hot water
about 75 degrees as it falls into the
mash tun and it forms like a porridge
smells a bit like Horlicks and oval team
it's a great start to the day
Britten's have been brewing beer for
more than 2,000 years and now the UK
boasts more breweries per head of the
population than any other country in the
world David Morgan Hewitt is less pub
culture and more high culture he's a man
who mixes in elite circles and he likes
his shopping bespoke german straightens
and James's is home to many of this
city's Royal Warrant orders companies
and trades people that are bestowed with
this lofty honour for services to the
royal family other thing I good to see
you again how are you in time for
another shirt please stay Turnbull &
Asser is a bespoke shirt maker but Royal
Warrant holders include jeweler's
hoteliers milliner's department stores
and even chocolatiers only favourites of
the Royals that you can enjoy - what
you'll find when you shop in
establishments that are being granted
the raw warrant is quality you're coming
into contact with people who really are
at the apex of their profession
Flores has been helping London's elite
smell nice for nearly 300 years this
Royal Warrant store has a range of
scents which give visitors a glimpse
into the past of London society this was
actually I think bespoke in the 1890s
for Duke Olaf who was a Russian
immigrant living in Paris but more
interestingly for us it became Winston
Churchill's favorite you can smell the
history in this store this one was made
for Ian Fleming who of course created
bond but venture a little further and
there's an opportunity to become a part
of this history
this is the holy of holies edward bottom
is the ninth generation of his family to
run this business
what we'll do is just start smelling and
smell a few different areas of the
fragrance wheel so something floral
something citrus something woody just to
get a feel for what type of scent you
like he specializes in the art of
perfume alchemy this is a fragrance that
dates back to 1700 s very sort of
citrusy is that lemony lime that was
because everything smells so disgusting
and people didn't bathe that much and
life was a bit smelly er Flores offers a
unique service for customers to create
their very own perfume and an
opportunity to be entered into Ledger's
alongside many of the Great's of English
society I think luxury is actually
changed I think a lot more about
people's perception of luxury is having
something unique and having something
exponential it smells like the inside of
an old antique drawer there's some black
peppercorn which gives it a spicy
element to it there are some citrus
notes in there
this is so much more personal and you've
been involved in it
when you go and visit a city like London
you want to get under the skin of it
what's great for visitors is to be able
to find these things and to to go off
the beaten track because actually people
in the know in London this is where they
come nothing says authentic London quite
like an evening at the dogs
kaby James is in Romford on the
outskirts of East London one of the last
remaining greyhound racing tracks left
in the city it's not an elitist
activities it's sudden everyone can
enjoy one of the other things I love
about going to the the dogs is the fact
that everyone's really welcoming so many
of the the dog tracks are now closing
down so if you want to get an authentic
sort of London experience like nothing
else you need to come while these places
are still open number four come on
you're number four it's a great
opportunity to meet some real characters
who live and breathe this sporting along
even at 50 odd years 15 teams heisting
we don't brush him when it was full gene
right so I enjoy
one male voice one is what happens to
these guys up there so no it's just
signaling to them all yes it's sign
language yeah it's just like when pick
the death you know that it's exactly
saying and I might say to you quick
quick what parts of three done you say
evens levels you Devils right three
later News at five to four among as the
money's going on
you're constantly gonna are trading all
the time
thank you sir well life's a number three
to win but she's not in it you can't win
that's truth good
there's a reason that going to the dogs
is often dubbed the Capitals fun night
out in Peckham in the southeast of the
city some of London's hippest residents
are preparing for an old-school
gathering for Megan and her mates
tonight is less about adrenaline and
more about getting back to basics the
campfire club is a fortnightly event
held in different green spaces of the
city we're here in one of the biggest
cities of the world you can see the
shards from the garden yet you've got
this real local sort of atmosphere it's
very feels quite intimate this is like a
time-honored tradition of coming
together around a blazing fire making
music telling stories and chatting and
getting to know each other
London's by far the greenest city in
Europe with 35,000 acres of public parks
so there's no shortage of locations to
enjoy alfresco music like this
severed heart free vaulted
Taurus wouldn't really know that
something like this was going to happen
isn't really hidden away it's very
welcoming anybody can come you can hear
about it by searching on the website and
your job or bears no justly London's got
a reputation for being unfriendly and
that people don't speak to each other
yet you can see here everyone talking
making friends getting to know each
other and being really friendly and
welcoming and you're hardening you're as
people here from everywhere just picked
someone from Romania of the person from
Brazil the person from Italy and we've
all come together to listen to this
absolutely beautiful music London might
be a mega city but it's best experienced
at a local level which is easily done
when you know where to look